bonjour et bienvenue au parlement
européen lors nous sommes dans le hall
où sont reçus les personnalités et dans
l'europe et dont nous allons parler d'un
autre tapis le tapis rouge de cannes
car c'est cette semaine que commence le
festival du film et on le sait peu le
cinéma européen est en partie financée
par des fonds de bruxelles
mais d'abord l'actualité tout le monde
avec la croissance mais de quelle
croissance parle-t-on c'est la question
de la semaine croissance croissance sur
le continent européen des voix s'élèvent
pour invoquer la croissance
les appels viennent de france d'espagne
d'italie et même du 35ème étage de
l'eurotower de francfort où siège le
gardien de l'orthodoxie monétaire
aujourd'hui ce que j'ai à l'esprit c'est
la nécessité d'un pacte de croissance
mais comment faire revenir la croissance
à l'horizon européen
en france le nouveau président de la
république réclame un changement en
europe
en ajoutant un volet croissance au pacte
de discipline budgétaire
pas si vite berlin met en garde la
croissance oui mais pas à n'importe quel
prix et surtout pas par la dette
baxter deux structures une croissance
par des réformes de fond est importante
et nécessaire mais nous ne voulons pas
d'une croissance à crédit qui nous
ramènerait au début de la crise nous ne
ferons pas ça à bruxelles en tout cas
les grands travaux sont lancés
la commission européenne envisage de
mobiliser près de 80 milliards de
ressources non utilisées pour faciliter
le financement de grands projets dans le
domaine des énergies renouvelables des
transports une sorte de plan marshall
européen qui tirerait d'affaires la
grèce le portugal l'espagne peut être
même la grande bretagne tous frappés par
la récession mais la volonté de
croissance est elle compatible avec
l'austérité
réponse au prochain conseil européen le
28 juin à bruxelles
et cette semaine pour commenter
l'actualité une députée allemande est
avec nous et evelyne gebhardt bonjour je
vous faites partie ici du groupe
socialistes et démocrates du spd
allemand qui est dans l'opposition à
angela merkel alors on parle de
croissance tout le monde
invoque la croissance mais on ne sait
pas très bien comment la faire venir et
puis surtout chacun a sa définition de
la croissance pour vous quelle quelle
est cette croissance est ce que c'est
une croissance par par la dette ou une
croissance au contraire à des réformes
structurelles comme la rue dit angela
merkel c'est un mélange des deux
probablement que nous devrons à faire
mais pas partie par les dettes mais nous
avons dans l'union européenne beaucoup
de ressources qui pour une raison ou une
autre ne peuvent pas être dépensés en ce
moment c'est assez étonnant vous direz
mais je pense qu'il faudrait prendre ses
ressources dans les fonds structuraux et
d'autres pour en faire vraiment un
un projet de croissance dans l'union
européenne pour que l'on puisse créer de
l'emploi pour que l'on puisse donner de
l'éducation jeunes leur peau proposer
aussi des métiers dans lesquels ils
peuvent survivre
ça ça n'occasionnera pas de nouvelles
dépenses finalement votre vision de la
croissance est quand même compatible
avec celle qui a défini ses comptes tout
à fait compatible avec ce que françois
hollande mais c'est aussi compatible
avec ce que veulent à la cites les
citoyens allemands qui sont très très
dur sur cette thématique et il faut les
écouter bien sûr ce qu'ils disent il
dénonce nous voulons l'arrêt guigoz it
et nous voulons que nos états fassent
des économies pour que les enfants dans
l'avenir ne soit pas obligé de payer les
dettes de leurs parents et leurs
grands-parents
c'est ça la discussion en allemagne il
faut le prendre en compte parce que nous
ne voulons pas que les enfants étant de
dette a dit avoir alors justement
comment les allemands regarde-t-il
certaine mesure
dans le programme du candidat françois
hollande devenu président de la
république tel retour du moins partielle
à la retraite à 60 ans comment voit-il
tout c'est toutes ces mesures je pense
que chaque gouvernement doit prendre ses
priorités nous avons une certaine zone
adam d'argent que nous pouvons dépenser
et nous devons faire des priorités ou
est ce que nous voulons dépenser cet
argent ça c'est que je n'en sors de là
c'est du ressort de ces du ressort de la
france c'est du ressort de l'allemagne
de le faire d'une autre manière si elle
le veut mais c'est du ressort de la de
la france de le faire c'est une décision
française et il faudra que bien sûr que
françois hollande comme madame mercun
respecte les traités de l'union
européenne dans lesquelles nous avons
aussi quelques critères de maastricht a
à prendre en compte mais cela ne
signifie pas que l'on ne peut pas faire
des réformes que l'on ne peut pas faire
des restructurations que ne peut pas
dire écoutez nous voulons faire en sorte
que l'argent soit dépensé de cette
manière là parce que nous voulons créer
de l'emploi parce que nous voulons avoir
un avertit un avenir une perspective
pour les citoyens alors le président
français le nouveau président de la
république français et la chancelière
allemande se sont vus à berlin pour la
première fois on ne connaît pas le
détail de ce qui s'est dit mais les
discussions s'annoncent un peu difficile
puisqu'ils ne sont pas forcément
d'accord sur le cap futur a donné à
l'europe sur quoi à votre avis
le compromis peut-il se faire et ce que
la volonté française de croissance est
compatible avec la recette allemand de
l'austérité il faudrait la faire et il
faudra le faire faudra que françois
hollande voit bien quelles sont les
possibilités dans l'union européenne
mais il faut aussi que madame est à que
se bouge un peu
elle ne peut pas rester sur ses
positions et dire je ne bouge pas ce
n'est pas possible vous voyez des signes
d'évolution alors même qu'elle genou en
difficulté dans certains scrutins
régionaux en allemagne elle est bien
obligé parce qu'elle elle voit bien que
même en allemagne on commence à discuter
d'une autre manière que l'on pense aussi
quelle est la situation des citoyens
dans l'union européenne en allemagne en
france et dans les autres pays donc il
faut donner des réponses à cela et un
grand progrès qui a été fait hier
mon avis c'est que on a dit dans ses
problèmes dans ces termes là il n'y a
plus de tabous on est tous les tous les
thèmes sur la table ce que madame merkel
ne voulait pas jusqu'à maintenant et
donc il ya déjà une avancée une
progression et je pense bien et j'espère
bien que ça va progresser encore un peu
plus est ce que vous pensez que
l'arrivée de françois hollande pour
changer quelque chose à la nature
hostile du couple franco allemand
on parle de france j'ai la marque land
est ce qu'il peut y avoir du nouveau duo
en europe
écoutez je ne suis pas sûr que
j'aimerais bien avoir ce france rende
enfin je n'en mets tes gars commencent à
céder les surnoms qui ont été données de
vente mercredi avait une connotation
négative en allemagne je ne sais pas
comment cette en france mais avait une
connotation négative qui disait aussi
que c'est un cas qui décide
ou alors ils veulent avancer la france
qui suit est jolie merkozy gris impose
sa loi à l'europe finale à et sabha
changement et cela va changer et il faut
que cela change parce que nous avons su
27 et pays dans l'union européenne
nous ne sommes pas que deux et je pense
que les autres pays ont un droit de
regard aussi sur la politique que nous
faisons en europe
alors il ya un pays qui inquiètent
là les dirigeants européens qui donnent
des sueurs froides à l'europe c'est bien
sûr la grèce avec deux nouveaux le
blocage et de nouvelles élections en vue
voyez tout de suite ce tour d'horizon
des télévisions européennes qui ont mis
la grèce à la une
regardez yen hsun newcastle l'allumage
de la flamme olympique qui a bien été
l'une des seules bonnes nouvelles en
provenance le grèce aujourd'hui la
deuxième tentative jeu de mise en place
d'une coalition autour d'alexis sip race
vient d'échouer
le leader de la gauche radicale ayant
expliqué qu'il tenait le programme de
réduction des déficits et des dépenses
pour nulle et non à vis des nuages
d'incertitudes planent sur athènes et
sur la zone euro la grèce n'a toujours
pas de gouvernement plus d'une semaine
après le résultat des élections
si les tentatives de former une
coalition échoue le pays devra retourner
aux urnes
la presse du jour parle de g et de
situations à haut risque et dans les
rues d'athènes la population résignée du
fromage et de la confiture ces produits
sont tous entièrement produit en grèce
mina est une ancienne journaliste
gastronomique elle a ouvert cette
épicerie grâce à ses propres économies
une exception sur la petite île de
lesbos qui grâce à ses riches haute ne
connaît pas la crise
quelles seraient les conséquences pour
la grèce d'un divorce avec la zone euro
c'est une question qui revient de plus
en plus souvent dans les interventions
des analystes en effet pour les
européens si la grèce n'accepte pas
d'appliquer les réformes imposées par
ses créanciers
elle doit à sortir de la zone euro
evelyne gebhardt que peut-il se passer
maintenant en grèce
si les nouvelles élections organisées ne
donne rien qu'est ce qui peut se passer
c'est le chaos l'austérité ou le chaos
quelle issue voyez vous si la grèce un
problème avec les votes en ce moment si
les résultats sont mauvais il y aura un
gros problèmes en grèce et les plus gros
gros problème ce sera pour l'épauler
pour les gens pour les personnes qui
sont déjà dans une situation très
précaire en grèce et j'espère bien que
les grecs vont comprendre cela qu'il
faut continuer à travailler mais je
pense aussi que l'europe doit aussi
faire un pas envers la grèce est
d'ailleurs la commission européenne a
dit qu'elle était prête à accepter aussi
de de ralentir les l'austérité qui est
demandé et je pense que la politique qui
va peut-être que j'espère va changer en
ce qui concerne la croissance aussi en
europe va avoir aussi quelques retombées
évidemment jusqu'au mois de juin ce ne
sera pas encore visible tout simplement
s'il n'y a pas de gouvernement pour
d'interlocuteurs pour né pas d'interview
comment cet avion est bloqué au moment
et c'est un gros problème et il faudra
voir quel sera l'interlocuteur après les
nouvelles élections au mois de juin
nous devons essayer de tout faire pour
que allure la grèce reste dans la zone
euro je pense
je donne tout à fait d'accord avec
merkel et hollande qui l'on dit très
clairement hier aussi ils ont ils ont
dit qu'il fallait faire quelque chose
pour la pour la grèce ça va me prendre
quelle forme
est-ce qu'il faut un talent particulier
j'ai loupé je ne saurais pas vous le
dire aujourd'hui bien sûr ce qu'ils ont
dans la tête mais il ya beaucoup d'idées
en ce moment de plan particulier pour la
grèce
voyez les fonds structuraux dans la
grèce ne peut pas profiter en ce moment
on pourrait peut-être en faire un
programme justement de
de croissance pour la grèce que l'argent
qui leur est dû
puisse être utilisé pour pour pour pour
les grecs pour leur donner une base de
d'économies pour que pour qu'il y ait
une certaine croissance qui se puisse
devenir parent et les emplois présents
et que des emplois faire en sorte que
l'éducation se remette en marche parce
que beaucoup de jeunes ne trouvent pas
de deux possibilités de se former de
formation et donc de créer dans ce
domaine là quelque chose on pourrait
créer aussi des start up des choses dans
ce journal
dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables par exemple parce qu'en
grèce il ya beaucoup de soleil il ya
beaucoup de vent on pourrait faire
quelque chose dans ce domaine là je
pense que c'est c'est dans cette voie là
dans cette direction là il faudrait
aller et donnez donc une perspective aux
gens est ce que tout ça ça ne représente
pas quelque chose une tâche gigantesque
dans la mesure où on a l'impression
qu'il faut tout reconstruire en grèce
ces gigantesques en effet en grèce et ça
ne va pas être fait en quelques mois ou
en quelques années savent à quel le tout
premier pas à faire pour le tout premier
pas à faire c'est de faire ce programme
de croissance pour qu'il ya une preuve
d'excès ccc british à ses héritiers de
louis la politique d'austérité est telle
qu'elle est formulée en ce moment là
elle met à mal l'économie grecque
elle crée la perte d'emploi dire que
concrètement les européens devraient
être un peu plus conciliant avec les
grecs c'est ça que
pas plus conciliant parce que nous avons
eues qu'il ya beaucoup de problèmes
qu'avec les grecs parce qu'il y avait un
manque de structure parce que les
européennes total de l'aide européenne
accordée a déjà un peu un peu de baisser
est ce que c'est une pression
supplémentaire mis sur les grecs pour
qu'il y ait une prochaine ère où ils ont
trait à la réforme
oui c'est ça c'est ça la question que je
me pose est ce que c'est vraiment la
bonne voie est ce que c'est vraiment ça
qu'il faut faire
moi moi je pense que oui bien sûr il
doit faire des économies c'est clair
parce qu'avec les dettes qu'ils ont ça
ne peut pas marcher
mais il faut aussi faire en sorte qu'ils
aient une possibilité d'avoir de
l'économie qu'il y ait qu'ils aient la
possibilité de gagner de l'argent pour
pouvoir rembourser les dettes à un
moment ou un autre mais il ya un autre
problème qui est structurelle aussi il
n'y a pas de vraie de du véritable
administration qui marchent
véritablement bien cela ôte
aussi il faudra le mettre en place il
faudra aiderez aider les grecs dans ce
domaine là ça va durer plusieurs années
une génération probablement mais il faut
loeb se mettre en route
on ne peut pas dire écoutez vous faites
des économies économisez économiser
économiser perdre et de l'emploi et
après ça marchera marchera pas ça ne
peut pas il faut du temps pour lui tant
merci beaucoup et bing et barda vent
était notre invité alors on va parler
aujourd'hui de cinéma alors que s'ouvre
le festival de cannes la culture
européenne et elle sacrifiée en période
d'austérité françois beaudonnet en
parlera avec son invitée après ce
reportage signé thibault le floch qui a
suivi serge bromberg qui restaure des
vieux films européens regarder
à
certaines de ces images où plus de cent
ans
venus des quatre coins du globe ces
films ont parfois passer des décennies
oublié dans des greniers
avant de retrouver une seconde vie grâce
à cet homme serge bromberg
en quarante ans ce cinéphile a constitué
une collection de plus de 100000 bobines
et avec sa société lobster films il
restaure chaque année une cinquantaine
de films anciens
il s'agit de mère française un film
produit en 1917 par la société et clips
donc film de guerre avec sarah bernhardt
est une copie nitrates d'époque de 1917
depuis quatre ans serge bromberg s'est
lancé un nouveau défi mettre à
disposition du plus grand nombre les
pépites les cinémathèques européenne
grâce à un site internet inédit europe a
fait une très jeune trésor des archives
européenne est une plateforme internet
gratuites d'accès où chaque cinémathèque
propose quelques unes de ces grandes
restaurations afin que cet ensemble
d'environ 200 films forme cette malle
aux trésors cette sorte de mémoire du
monde tels que l'europe l'a constitué
film d'animation votre ville ou bien
encore documents historiques
tous les genres sont représentés un site
interactif qui permet de valoriser les
fonds de 30 et une cinémathèque
européennes obtient ce film restauré à
belgrade en serbie salaires formidable
j'allais voir ce qu'ils font à belgrade
clic et on se retrouve sur le site de la
cinémathèque de belgrade dans la langue
qu'on a choisi puisque repas filtrage
heures et dans les cinq langues
européennes plus la langue native quand
c'est le roumain le tchèque ou des
choses comme ça donc voilà on est dans
une sorte de 2,2 vitrine de formidable
vitrine où on peut même goûté consommer
incroyable quoi
et pour apprécier un film
rien de mieux qu'une véritable salle de
cinéma comme celle du palais des
beaux-arts de bruxelles de sécurité en
véritable showman serge bromberg
n'hésite pas à donner de sa personne
pour partager sa passion du 7e annoncé
très dangereux si vous en avez n'hésitez
pas de savoir si ça marche
amelio à la cinémathèque royale de
belgique attention ça va super bien
c'est la 5 portes ces étranges lunettes
c'est pour apprécier la projection en 3
dimensions de films parfois tourné au
tout début du 20e siècle
des films de méliès projeté en 3d une
vidéothèque européenne gratuite sur
internet
l'utilisation de ces nouvelles
technologies a séduit l'union européenne
elle finance d'ailleurs 50% du site de
serge goldberg europe a fini très jeune
ce qui est important avec ce projet qui
a reçu un soutien dans notre laboratoire
de tests qui lé projet pilote
ce qui est intéressant pour nous c'est
l'application des nouvelles technologies
entre 2007 et 2013
le programme média a consacré 755
millions d'euros pour soutenir le cinéma
européen
une aide vitale pour les créateurs dont
300 projets de films sont ainsi financés
chaque année
chaque année nous avons à cannes des
films qui ont reçu des subventions aux
médias que ce soit dans le développement
ou la distribution par exemple l'année
dernière où nous avons fêté nos 20 ans
du programme média nous avions 21 films
dans la sélection à cannes en 2013 le
parlement européen devra voter un
nouveau budget pour le programme média
qui courra jusqu'à 2020 les
professionnels du cinéma espère que les
subventions de bâtir une pas trop de la
crise histoire de pouvoir continuer à
tenir tête ou géant en ligne voilà pour
ce joli reportage signé thibault le
floch alors nous avons été rejoints par
marie christine vergiat bonjour bonjour
vous êtes eurodéputée française vous
êtes membre ici au parlement européen à
bruxelles de la commission de la culture
on l'a vu dans ce reportage l'europe
finance une partie du cinéma européen et
pourtant ne le sais pas si on demande
aux gens ce que fait l'europe
personne ne va dire que l'europe finance
une partie du cinéma européen
comment ça se fait que les cette
ignorance comme ça
on connaît très mal fonctionnement des
institutions européennes
et c'est d'ailleurs tout
particulièrement vrai en france
je crois qu'il ya une responsabilité des
médias en la matière excusez moi
ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas le cas
de
de la chaîne parlementaire qui est une
rare des rares chaînes françaises a
véritablement consacrer des émissions
aux questions européennes
mais quand on regarde l'ensemble des
médias de quoi l'on parle
en ce moment la crise le problème de
l'euro les questions économiques et on
parle jamais du reste alors l'europe est
capable du meilleur et du pire et on
nous montre uniquement le pire
donc c'est la faute des médias n'ont pas
seulement la faute des médias mais un
des enjeux c'est comment on fait en
sorte que les citoyens s'intéressent
plus aux questions européennes
mais josé manuel barroso par exemple au
ici au parlement européen enfin moi je
suis depuis quelques années j'ai jamais
entendu parler à un responsable européen
du cinéma européen
c'est c'est une question qui est souvent
marginales y compris dans les enjeux
européens sur le budget culture par
exemple régulièrement chaque année le
parlement européen a rétabli les crédits
consacrés à la culture
ils ne sont pourtant pas très important
c'est 0,05 pour cent du budget de
l'union européenne
mais à chaque fois la commission en
accord avec le conseil nous présente un
budget revu à la baisse
donc ça montre qu'elle est la priorité
accordée à cette question et c'est vrai
que quand on regarde les grands débats
des institutions européennes la culture
à une place marginale
là vous avez donné un chiffre qui dit ce
qu'il veut dire 0 05 % donc c'est très
très peu il ya les grands budgets comme
la politique agricole commune qui font
par exemple 30 ou 40%
est ce que justement c'est pas là le lac
la question le souci c'est en fait
finalement quand même peu d'argent et au
delà de ça d'ailleurs on peut se poser
la question est-ce que c'est à l'europe
de financer la culture
je crois que c'est des questions de
priorité ça dépend quelle europe on veut
construire effectivement 50% du budget
de l'union européenne et ont sacré la
politique agricole commune
donc il ya besoin de redéfinir un
certain non
deux priorités et de questions quand il
s'agit d'aller trouver de l'argent pour
les banques
on trouve assez facilement mais
milliards pour se sauver des banques
avec les résultats que l'on connaît
notamment en grèce sur ces questions là
pour moi c'est des questions qui sont
tout aussi essentiels d'abord parce que
c'est une question fondamentale pour la
formation des citoyens à l'avenir le
reportage que nous avons vues
extraordinaires de ce point de vue c'est
la restauration de films anciens pour
protéger notre patimo patrimoine
culturel ça devrait être une des
priorités on dit sans arrêt le
patrimoine européen mais il faut le
démontrer dans les actes dans les actes
politiques et dans les actes budgétaires
pour le moment ce n'est pas le cas on
voit bien quels sont les priorités il ya
des beaux discours
ça a du mal à se traduire dans les actes
en termes de priorités politiques alors
les états européens n'ont plus un sou
tous
est ce que il n'est pas normal ou malgré
tout qu'en période de crise il est
peut-être moins d'argent alors vous
citiez l'exemple des banques s qui est
pas normal quand les moins d'argent pour
la culture que pour les secteurs qui
sont plus directement et immédiatement
vitaux dans l'économie je pense que
le secteur de la culture est un secteur
vital pour l'économie la culture c'est
5% du pib
c'est pas négligeable 5 % du pib c'est
un prêt de 2 % de l'emploi en europe le
secteur culturel et c'est un texte
secteur qui a une énergie extraordinaire
on dit en creative innovation l'arrivée
des nouvelles technologies frappe ce
secteur qui est en plein bouleversement
donc si on veut protéger le patrimoine
européen si on veut que le cinéma
européen continue à avoir une place sur
la scène mondiale il faut lui donner les
moyens de résister aux grands groupes
américains en la matière comment ça se
passe alors ça peut se passer par par
des subventions donc par de l'argent de
l'argent européen mais est ce que c'est
suffisant ou est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
mesures qu'il faudrait prendre selon
vous je pense que le soutien à la
création est quelque chose de
fondamental c'est d'ailleurs un des
objectifs premiers du programme du
programme média
ça ne fait pas tout mais quand on
regarde comment se comportent les
différents cinémas européens parce qu'en
fait le cinéma européen c'est une
addition finalement des cinémas des
états membres
le cinéma français résiste mieux que la
plupart que l'ensemble même des autres
cinémas européens
si le cinéma français résiste mieux
c'est parce qu'il a un système de
financement qui est très particulier
c'est le financement par le cnc par des
taxes sur sur le cinéma sur les
télévisions est maintenant sur les
fournisseurs d'accès à internet
ces menaces et tout ça mais je pense que
ça fait partie effectivement des choses
qui sont fondamentales mais c'est aussi
la place que l'on accorde à ces
questions notamment dans le secteur
éducatif est ce que vous nous dites
qu'il faudrait transposer le système
français de financement de cinéma au
niveau européen c'est toujours difficile
de répondre de cette façon parce que
l'union européenne est une mosaïque et
sa richesse et sa diversité donc il est
toujours difficile de transposer un
modèle qui n'existe que dans un seul
pays mais
on peut avoir des discussions en la
matière le
programme média a montré son utilité
donc on peut peut-être combiner ce que
fait le programme média avec ce que font
les
ce que fait le cinéma français justement
parce que c'est un peu un exemple et
puis peut-être qu'il faut regarder
pourquoi
alors qu' il ya une énorme production en
termes de cinéma en europe
pourquoi la masse des recettes va aux
films américains on a des questions à se
poser en la matière est-ce que là on est
en plein festival de cannes est ce que
vous pourriez nous dire un petit peu
quel est l'état des lieux justement du
cinéma européen
est ce que vous êtes inquiète oui et non
je pense que
il ya une richesse or l'europe est d'un
peu le berceau du cinéma a d'une
certaine façon
donc il ya une richesse extraordinaire
le prix lux qui est le prix du parlement
européen cherche à justement valorisé
cette diversité européenne et à la faire
connaître en sous titrant chaque année
un film dans donc il ya une production
qui est très riche
il ya toujours eu d'extraordinaire c'est
un stand mais si on ne fait rien pour
protéger cette production
avec notamment ce qu'on a appelé
l'exception culturelle eh bien on risque
d'aller vers de plus en plus un cinéma
de divertissement
qui a son rôle à jouer mais qui ne peut
pas
couvrir l'ensemble du cinéma européen
est ce que oui d'une certaine façon ce
que l'on voit en espagne au portugal en
italie en angleterre est assez
inquiétant de ce point de vue donc la
france peut être un exemple dans sa
capacité à résister justement en la
matière merci beaucoup marie christine
vergiat donc pour une exception
culturelle européenne
exerçant merci encore c'est la fin
d'europe et bleu on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec kathia gilder
bien sûr d'ici là bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires